now that was the hard way there was a
lot of working like that okay but i
wonder if it tweeds with you as we're
going through particularly around here
we will do this integral and these
things cancel out you've got to be
really suspicious in the answer right
it's very very it's very simple okay how
could we have seen it from here without
doing this whole translation and for new
integrals in that work okay well if your
graph is any good come back to the first
time you graph this question okay now
where r for fits and pie on this diagram
right well for Fitz is is this with here
and this with hidden right and pi is
where spire clockwise the height of the
whole graph right you see it can you see
it yet for Fitz why pi radian time it's
just a rectangle okay so what's the easy
way here's the easy way now I'll admit
it would be nice fragrance write down
the equations but see what I just did
there okay unfortunately or maybe
fortunately you don't get to go to the
marker and on you know get a whiteboard
out and draw this and then color didn't
say tada okay so we need to provide
something verbal that explains what I
just did okay so here's what i would
suggest on your diagram you must have a
diagram okay do some labeling I've got
three areas here okay which I'm
interested in okay i can say on the
definition write this integral is equal
to those two bottom areas okay because
they are the areas underneath the curve
okay so i haven't made any dramatic
statements here okay but then i can say
and you should have some more space here
to actually make this but I'm just going
to go into the next line from the graph
because you actually do need to have a
graph drawn to make this argument okay
from the graph I can say that these two
areas are equivalent right assume your
graph is good enough right answer equals
a 3 on what principle are their
equivalent and the answer is symmetry
it's not an even function or an odd
function but if you rotate it around
this point zero pile too okay you'll get
h to becoming a 3 just by rotating
element okay so i would say my sentry
just a bathroom truth now I'm sort of
doing both of these right so if I if I
didn't have the graph I can't argue by
symmetry right but having got a graph
where it's clear yes I can okay so
therefore the integral is equal to a1
plus a3 which is a rectangle which is
that wide and that time and that's the
evaluation okay so should you do it the
easy way or the hard way assuming you
can spot it right clearly the easy way
is better no you can't you can't make
any of the items without the graph you
must must must have a wrap okay you
can't simply go from here to here right
sorry no yeah even if you only say this
it's not enough if you don't have some
kind of illustration yeah into question
tomorrow so that usually mean so yeah
people will see I'd expect this to be on
you know this would be the question and
I expect it to have two maps and many
people will start doing it the normal
way that you do one of these kinds of
areas and they'll be like well though
either realize something is wrong okay
but but might not work out that they can
do this trick maybe because they're
graph is but I remember the first time I
looked at a question like this my um my
client inverse curve was so off I
literally could not see the symmetries
because it wasn't symmetrical on my
diagram right so if you don't split it
you're like okay I'll get hit eventually
but yeah you're still get the same to
mark me like that was a lot of work
because you didn't realize that was a
people i did still want to show you that
boat because this is useful this is
instructive this identity okay I'm just
to go back to Daniel suggested it it's
also good point you cosimo some troops
like that right and minus cos inverse is
the same thing but Flint right so you
think about you edition but of ordnance
right you've got pi plus zero which is
PI point line is your pie on to possibly
on to which is apply you've got zero
plus plan to again and then every point
you think about how this is decreasing
and this is increasing its a brain so
that's why you're going to get a
straight line namely y equals plan okay
so that that i will also works but i
wanted to show you that you can use the
methods with the dual rate the algebraic
methods to show you i didn't mean this
just like you can use say sine squared
plus y squared equals 1 it comes out of
the fact that it comes out of all of
these facts there are other ones like
that right for instance without actually
proving it I wonder how many of you
could tell me good guess what this is
equal to I think about it it's very very
similar to this but not quiet what's the
difference between sine inverse of X in
causing myself minus X what's the
difference remember when we're looking
integration we look the difference
a shift it's a constant right so the
equal to phone yeah that's right if sine
inverse of x is cos inverse of minus X
brought down pi on two units okay so
seeing as the whole thing is brought
down pile onto you you expect it should
be planned to less than this which is
part two okay you can verify by
differentiating as well because you can
you know what these two derivatives are
it's constant then you evaluate about